today we're going to be doing goodie bag
1
atoms and reactions our objectives today
are to identify material based on its
properties
observe a simple chemical reaction and
identify the limiting reagent
and estimate the number of atoms in a
real object
to do this goodie bag you'll need
vinegar a plastic cup
a ruler metal samples of aluminum copper
iron magnesium and tin but if you can
only get copper and magnesium it will
work
and a pipette some conceptual questions
to think about while you're doing this
goodie bag are
how can we tell different metals apart
and how can we count
atoms that are too small to see first we
have five samples of metal that we would
like to identify
using their properties the easiest to
identify is copper
by its orangish color next we're going
to try to find out which sample is iron
by testing how easy they are to bend
iron will be the most difficult to bend
so this sample bends very easily just
with my fingers so it must not be iron
this sample is very difficult i can
hardly get it to bend at all
with my fingers and this sample also
bends fairly easily just using my
fingers
so we know that this sample the hardest
to bend must be iron
next we're going to try to compare the
density of these different metals
so this metal feels the heaviest and
most dense
this one feels lighter and this sample
feels light as well
so we know that tin is the most dense
metal so this sample must be tin
to identify which of these samples is
magnesium and which of them is aluminum
we're going to test which one of them
reacts with vinegar
[Music]
so we're going to place each of these
samples on the lid of our plastic cup
to make sure we don't spill any of the
vinegar
and use our pipette to put a drop of
vinegar on each of the samples
and the one that reacts will be
magnesium because we know magnesium
reacts with vinegar
watch closely
it doesn't look like we're getting any
reaction from this metal so it must be
the aluminum now let's try the other
you can see that this material is
forming tiny bubbles after we put the
vinegar on it
so it must be magnesium those bubbles
are hydrogen gas
now that the bubbling has stopped on our
magnesium we know that the reaction is
over
there's still plenty of magnesium left
so this indicates that the acetic acid
inside of the vinegar must be the
limiting reagent
finally we want to estimate how many
atoms are in our sample of copper
to do so we're going to use a ruler
using our ruler we can measure the width
and the height
of this copper sample so using the
metric side of our ruler
we align the zero with the edge of our
material
and see that it is about 13 millimeters
wide
and 25 millimeters long today we did
goodie bag one
we identified our metal samples based on
their material properties
we observed a simple reaction and
identified the limiting reagent
and we measured our copper to estimate
the number of atoms in our sample